Japan is set to host the Olympics in 149
days but right now domestic sporting
events are taking a major hit as the
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a and his
government tried to curb the spread of
coronavirus look I got the mother you're
not considering that there's a large
risk of infection for nationwide sports
and cultural events where a large number
of people gather we will consider
measures such as suspension postponement
and reduction of size for the next two
weeks worrying times for organizers of
Tokyo 2020 which has been seven years in
the making at a cost of more than 20
billion dollars the games start in July
with 11 thousand athletes expected to
compete and hundreds of thousands of
fans set to attend on Tuesday dick pound
the longest-serving member of the
International Olympic Committee said the
games are under threat and that a call
needs to be made within three months
however the Japanese government quickly
moved to play down those comments my
dudes can't get through that they go
such keen going up the Games Organising
Committee has checked with the IOC
regarding this with regard to this
members comment the IOC has responded
that this is not their official position
and that the IOC is proceeding with
preparations towards the games as
scheduled the games may still be on but
coronavirus has already made its mark on
the event several qualifying tournaments
have been postponed across several
sports from boxing to badminton
but Olympic Committee's around the world
are still preparing to compete and come
July we're taking it very seriously
we're not going to just walk through the
next few months you know avoiding the
conversation we're dealing with it we're
taking good advice and we remain as our
partners are the IOC and the Tokyo
government and the organizing community
confident the guys will go ahead there
has been talk of possibly moving the
games to London which hosted back in
2012 but it's unlikely given the
logistics involved and the limited time
available listen if you were going to do
this you should have fired up there
they're moving bands two months ago this
is not enough time Japan you'll never
get it done it's donkey or bus the
modern Olympics has only ever been
cancelled on three occasions since it
began in 1890
six each time because of war and the
longer the battle against coronavirus
drags on the more Tokyo 2020 is at risk
of suffering the same fate david stokes
al jazeera